now we're not talking about
a pregnancy that's due to rape but now
about a pregnancy that's due to a
consensual act but in which neither
neither willing partner were interested
in producing a baby either they were
stupid or their birth control failed or
something else right
the fact is that men and women are
different and again every human being
has ever recognized this and it's just
in the last you know two minutes um in
human history not even so um that some
number of people have been gleefully
pretending that that's not the case
um but that
when such uh a situation happens
it is one and only one of the two people
who are participating on whom the entire
um
brunt rests right
and
uh that is unfair
and it's real and there's nothing to be
done about the unfairness men and women
are different it's biologically unfair
it is biologically unfair and biology
has handed us some number of things
that
render us
different and in some cases that
difference actually makes us unequal
that's just true
and with regard to the sexes
which uh you know there there are there
are many places we can talk about this
i've talked elsewhere in here as well
about you know differences in interests
greater variability and intelligence in
men um compared to women but you know
same average intelligence you know and
you know a different amount of like
myelination in the brain different sizes
of corpus callosums like so many things
besides the totally obvious things that
every human being has ever noticed so
okay that's true
it takes two to tango it takes two to
make a pregnancy and then we have the
pregnancy is only manifest in the woman
so this is this is
a feminist issue in that it's not just a
woman's issue it's a human issue that uh
pertains to to men as well but it is a
feminist issue in that
we should be figuring out how to
decrease the number of unwanted
pregnancies as much as possible
allow women who find themselves in the
position of having
gotten into an unwanted pregnancy a way
to get out of that as early as possible
with the understanding that the woman
did not get herself into that situation
on her own there was a man involved as
well
so that not just men who are free and
clear once they maybe make a mistake
that results in a pregnancy but women
too
can
move forward with greater wisdom with
greater caution and with still the
capacity to make the difference in the
world that they want to make
i believe that that's right and i
believe that we
um
we make this argument in a different way
in our book and i think really this is
the point about the middle ground here
which is
you and i are not we will be understood
to be arguing for
some
return to the past and that is exactly
not what we are arguing we are arguing
for a renegotiation and the problem is
we had a very
naive renegotiation or maybe a total
failure to negotiate anything at the
sexual revolution where it just became a
free-for-all that has brought us to this
absurd and
exploitative
uh moment in history in which let's let
women behave like men at the worst right
exactly which doesn't uh make women
happy not let like let's let actually
because you did and you said this before
like we aren't like let for sure but
let's encourage right like let's let's
really push for you know everyone to
behave like
i don't know i won't say but men at
their worst right like no why why would
we do that why would we encourage
newly bad behavior um like the bad
behavior that one sex is already
engaging and sometimes
why would we try to spread that around
it's not even encouraged we actually
make women feel bad if they're not into
the idea of casual sex even though
the reason i mean the irony here and one
of the reasons that you
have to take a evolutionary biological
perspective not to figuring out what to
do next but to understanding how we
ended up here right the fact is
in fact i saw i saw claire layman say on
twitter yesterday
um that
uh
basically if you
um
if she was talking to men and she said
something like if you're the kind of man
who would [ __ ] a woman that you wouldn't
want to marry if she got pregnant and
you oppose abortion you're a hypocrite
now i don't actually disagree with what
i think she's trying to say but the word
hypocrite doesn't belong in there
because the fact is men are wired to try
to impregnate women who will not require
them to invest it's something we should
oppose it's utterly immoral
but the point is that is actually an
evolutionary wiring and women
are wired to prevent men from getting
away with it right and this actually
irony of ironies produces the asymmetry
in men and women that actually
causes all of the intrigue around
romance right this is you know it's a
very ugly way for this dynamic to get
started but the point is actually a lot
of the richness of human existence is
downstream of this right
forcing bad men to reveal their intent
and therefore limiting your choices to
good men who are interested in investing
in you long term is you know that's what
courtship is about and so in any case
i don't know how we have this discussion
if we have to pretend that's not true
right the asymmetry exists it's handed
to us from a long lineage of ancestors
it is modified radically at the point
that um
that control of birth becomes a
conscious choice
due to technology well there's a
i mean this is obviously a much longer
conversation
but there's a
conflation between
fast easy sex that's in front of me
and sexual pleasure
and the conflation results both in the
confusion that you're talking about
right now that if you
if you yourself say you know what casual
sex not for me you are understood to be
a prude who actually isn't interested in
sexual pleasure
um similarly at least one more example
of this although i think there are
likely to be many is um and this is true
i think more for men than for women but
if you are a
man
who says actually i don't watch porn
in fact you are much more likely to be
um a wonderful partner for some woman
who actually cares much more
and you know and gets more sexual
pleasure yourself but actually is able
to provide more but you are understand
understood by society to be
out of the loop somehow weird like
what's that about right and that is
backwards that is the backwards version
of what should actually be understood
with regard to
um how you know how porn
is twisting uh especially
men's especially young men's
visions of what sex is and what
relationship is and what sexual pleasure
can be
and um similarly casual sex
um but
yes a little different well
so we we belittle women who do not sign
up for no
we in society the little women for not
signing up for symmetry with men which
as you point out here is absurd because
we shouldn't expect them to have a
symmetrical view
now men are certainly wired to find the
prospect of um
commitmentless sex very exciting because
it's such an evolutionary bargain right
and the point
i don't i don't know if we've made this
point anywhere exactly but
i would argue
you know we we have made this argument
in several different places that uh
men have two reproductive strategies the
no investment one and the high
investment one and the high investment
one is not the same as the female
strategy but it's similar and the level
of investment and the level of
choosiness just over consistently it's
three
well i i'm going to lump the okay so one
of them obviously is rape which has
happened far too much
i mean any is too much but the point is
there's been a lot of it and it is a no
investment strategy and i think i think
it's not useful to lump them i think
because for the following reason they're
you know they're large broadly speaking
there are three male reproductive
strategies
there is rape which is
should be universally understood to be
deplorable and and we should try to
minimize that to zero
there is the um
you know love them and leave them
the cad the cad there a lot of these but
you're one of your students also had a
oh uh so and go sew and go the sew and
go strategy um which is the strategy
that has historically been only a male
strategy but which now women are being
encouraged to engage in and then there
is the um investment with a partner and
in the children that result strategy
which we don't have a fancy name for and
that's maybe part of why it's not as
obviously sexy um but you know you were
lumping those first two together and i i
don't think that's useful because it
will be harder for those people who are
finding success with so and goes like
hey this is fun like what i'm not a
rapist like what are you doing why would
you worry about that right
it was my error to lump them and one of
the reasons that it's my error is
because what i said is that men are
wired to find commitment-less sex uh
exciting and and the point is and some
some cretans do it one way and some do
it another way right and i would point
out just flag for later um one of the
insane things that we are allowing to
happen is an awful lot of rape play in
porn and elsewhere and this is
normalizing that which is making it uh
more likely to occur in the world when
in fact what we need to do is take the
potential for rape and rule it out at
the software level right right
societally we need to discourage um yeah
that's not actually that's actually not
okay right but nonetheless let's let's
take the two
strategies that are short of force yes
of men okay so you've got one strategy
which is so and go no investment and the
other strategy which is high investment
and is
yin yang symmetrical with the female
strategy
one of these the so and go strategy
is antagonistic
okay
the
high investment strategy is
collaborative and so
in my opinion we ought to be
discouraging antagonistic sexual
relations it's bad for society it's bad
for the people who participate in them
do i want to tell you you're not allowed
to do that no you're allowed to do it
but
do
i think it's a good idea
no right it's like you know
um you know if you if you own a
beautiful house should you you know go
at it with a sledgehammer and have a
bonfire in the living room no you
shouldn't should be allowed to i guess
but um
you know it's it it's not wise yeah
right
um so anyway i don't know i don't know
whether um that distinction will land
for people or not but i think the point
a i think it's liable to be less
intuitive for women because if you're
not a man you may not understand that
this is actually that you know
one of the attractions that men have for
women is not collaborative or flattering
right right it's predatory
and the fact is yes we can make it low
consequence
so the predatory you know it's a it's
play predation but
basically the idea of
sticking a woman with a pregnancy and
not intending to take care of that
consequence yes it's an evolutionary
bargain and you know
you know so might invading your neighbor
country because they don't have a lot of
weapons right it's not
just because it's a evolutionary winner
doesn't make it defensible that's right
[Music]